I've never done a movie a sequel to a
film before I've never come back as a
character older Elle Fanning returns as
Aurora in the Maleficent sequel out
later this year it's kind of fun that
you can do an indie movie like this and
then do a big blockbuster like
Maleficent and the people is coming up I
know so soon the first one was very much
an origin story mm-hmm what is going on
in this sequel well what can you say I
can't say but we have an amazing cast
Michelle Pfeiffer and yeah achoo hotel
before it's like amazing so I'm really
excited for the cast and it's really um
what's so nice is with this story I
don't know about things you much but it
really follows kind of the family
dynamic of like the mother-daughter
relationship interest the Kane Aurora
I'm Maleficent which is also was really
like the heart of the first movie at the
end and we get to to have that I've
never done a movie a sequel to a film
before I've never come back as a
character older and the first time it
was released when I was 16 but when I
shot that I was 14 and now I'm 20 so it
was like a big jump a big difference and
so Aurora is a young woman now what was
it like working with Michelle Pfeiffer
oh she's incredible it was so funny cuz
she has um like my if she was an I am
Sam with my sister and my sister was
really young so and my mom and my sister
just for like they look like my mom is
like loves Michelle I feel like she was
so nice to us like it was so important
is super young just starting out and
like that made like a huge impression on
my family and so kind of getting to come
back around and now I got to work with
her we'll have to wait until October for
that but Ella's currently starring in
teen spirit out later this month
[Music]
Elle plays violets a singer who enters a
competition show I read that you were
very inspired by pop stars like Taylor
Swift staying Katy Perry who were you on
the phone with if anyone oh no one you
know what's so sad when they were in
London for some reason the whole cast
like before the filming started they had
a big lunch and I wasn't in London yet
and Katy Perry came to the lunch I'm
limited time with all the cast and
they're like sitting me photos I was
like like I've met her before I haven't
met her and my sister knows her a bit
and so I hadn't met but I was I don't
like no world you know like super well
so that was sad but no I watched so I
just had YouTube okay has she seen the
movie but she has apparently she has and
she sent something very nice back I
think she liked it
[Music]
the actress says she trained for three
months with several vocal coaches for
the flick and same live we would like to
offer violet
do you want to pursue a singing career
you know I would you know I actually
would I who knows like not Oh career I
don't know how I would never I'm still
act and would love to I mean obviously
still act and that's my my thing but
it's cool like it opened the door to
that and I would never say no to maybe
you know who knows I really enjoyed it
like I really enjoyed it
[Music]